and president biden will speak today on
russia's full-scale invasion and many
are wondering what the u.s can do at
this point to stop the violence so let's
bring in special report and fox news
chief political anchor bret baer brett
the president met virtually with the g7
leaders this morning he was scheduled to
speak at noon and we've just found out
that has been pushed just a little bit
to 12 30 p.m you hearing anything
yeah well that meeting on the situation
room with his national security council
and then a virtual meeting with the g7
leaders remember germany is the
president of the g7 this year uh talking
about next steps talking about the next
tranche of sanctions as you talked about
before this was a
tiered approach um and the first tranche
got some criticism for not being hard
enough this next
level of sanctions is a different ball
game according to officials we're
talking to in that meeting
this morning also the secretary of
defense secretary of state and secretary
of treasury with treasury obviously
playing a significant role in how
sanctions are rolled out across the
world and the danger obviously is that
other countries in europe are going to
feel this directly
when these sanctions especially on
energy are deployed but stopping putin
is the number one goal yeah brett you
were listening to carl a moment ago
what are you hearing or thinking or
analyzing when it comes to the strength
that the american president must show
today
i think that their
that president biden's whole uh playbook
is to make sure that whenever he speaks
he speaks with all of the world leaders
uh the allies uh standing by his side
and essentially singing from the same
sheet of music and thereby getting more
powerful in the message that he's
delivering i was interested to see
the uk prime minister boris johnson and
his remarks this morning
he obviously
criticized and lambasted this move by
putin and said the world needs to stop
it but then he went on to say how
important this was for the world
because it sends a message elsewhere and
specifically talking about china and
taiwan and just this morning taiwanese
defense ministry said that nine chinese
airplanes crossed into their airspace
and the chinese government said taiwan
is not ukraine and the taiwan taiwanese
president upped the military
alert
in taiwan so
you know we were looking obviously
through this soda straw and kiev and
it's it's really dangerous and there's
going to be fighting and people are
going to die continue to die
but broader there's a bigger message for
the world
yeah speaking of that um if you go back
to 1994 and the agreement that was made
as ukraine gave up its nuclear weapons
as part of that budapest meeting
that the we would help protect ukraine
and we are not doing that
so america and the west once again
i mean i guess they could say well we
provided them some aid but i think for
the ukrainians would think well like
this is this is not enough as they flee
to the west and now president biden is
getting ready brett to give a state of
the union address in just a few days and
this next few days is going to be
extremely busy for him
and he's going to have to show a lot of
strength and they're planning to be in
the chamber on tuesday night with a
reduced-sized crowd with everyone having
to be masked up
even though most of the rest of the
world has moved on from the pandemic or
else figure out a way to live with it it
just feels a little bit discordant as we
head into the state of the union no
you're right and it's going to be a
challenge for this president to stream
and tie all of those things together in
a coherent message this obviously takes
front and center right now as the world
watches this but we have bigger
issues and now with crude oil
and oil hitting 105
for
you start thinking about the
implications for americans
down the road and there's going to be a
lot i think in this speech today
about the costs and the suffering that
we as americans may face
thank you brett we'll be back with you
shortly as well okay 12 30 we expect the
worst that will see be we'll be seeing
brett all day appreciate all right